big things are coming to the Marvel
Universe as it has been confirmed that
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios will be attending cc X P
otherwise known as the comic-con
experience in South Paulo Brazil next
weekend and we have reports from
omellete a who are the people who put on
CC XP according to their official
Twitter account Kevin Feige is going to
be kicking things off with a big MCU
panel welcome back everyone it's Warren
and if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe and hit the bell so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU the annual CC XP in South
Paulo Brazil is here once again and
Kevin Feige is going to be in attendance
and he's going to be bringing a lot with
him now if you're not aware big things
happen at CC XP last year we got the
Captain Marvel clip of her escape in the
scroll ship and we got some spider-man
far from home scenes as well that they
showed to the audience both exclusive to
CC XP and this year Kevin Feige gets 45
minutes to talk that's twice as long as
he got at the d23 event for Disney not
quite as long as the San Diego Comic Con
panel but still 45 minutes is enough
time to talk about a lot of new stuff
coming to the MCU Kevin Feige has
already stated that they have all of
phase 5 completely mapped out it's
already done he is even officially
stated before that they intended on
releasing phase 5 at San Diego Comic Con
as well but they decided against it
thinking that it was already too much in
phase 4 to cram into one panel but now
Marvel has a 45 minute panel to talk
about the future of the MCU now there
are a few things that will most likely
happen for starters the Black Widow
trailer should be out by the time that
CC XP comes around next Saturday the
trailer is expected to drop either
December 2nd or December 3rd which means
at CC XP we should get some exclusive
footage for Black Widow this would be
different from the trailer as we would
have just gotten the Black Widow trailer
a few days before but another thing that
we could possibly get is something from
the Eternals we know that the Eternals
is a big movie for Marvel and phase 4
one of the biggest movies that they're
doing it has a huge star-studded cast
and filming has been going on for some
time now so they could perhaps show us
some photos of characters and costumes
or they could show us some footage that
they've already shot for the movie this
won't be a trailer as they're not nearly
that far
but they could show us a little clip
after all the Eternals aren't that
well-known and Marvel will want to
spread the awareness of the movie around
but most importantly since Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios himself
will be there at the panel to talk about
the future of the MCU we should be
getting a lot of information about phase
5 we know a good majority of the films
that are going to come and phase 5 but
Marvel does like to throw us a fastball
there has been talks of the Fantastic
Four the x-men and Deadpool now being
Disney properties and now being worked
on by Disney perhaps Disney has plans
for one of these properties to be in
phase 5 and perhaps it's time to reveal
that to us there's also potential for
solo properties such as the Silver
Surfer that Marvel can do now that we've
all been waiting for as well and
although no one knows anything perhaps
Marvel could let us know what they're
planning for the future of the MCU
next Saturday so a lot is coming from CC
XP in Sao Paulo Brazil next Saturday be
sure you're ready there will definitely
be some news about the future of the MCU
and hopefully we'll see some footage
from phase 4
they are also releasing the Wonder Woman
1984 trailer if anybody's interested
I'll be covering that as well so be sure
to subscribe to my channel so you don't
miss anything leave a like on this video
if you enjoyed it and comment down below
with your thoughts on this that'll also
enter you in my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and click the
link down below for your chance to win
an Infinity Gauntlet as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
you